-I remember my -- I'm trying to
think of my worst costume.
I always forget.
They were always pretty bad,
but I remember one time
we bought --
you know the costumes that come
in the box with the cellophane,
and it was Batman.
I think it was Batman.
-Yeah.
-And my mom made me wear
a sweatshirt over it.
[ Light laughter ]
So basically I was a kid in
a sweatshirt with a Batman mask.
[ Laughter ]
And I had been wearing
it all day.
I was so excited to wear it,
that I had chewed the plastic.
Mouth -- I was, like,
chewing on the mouth thing,
and it cut my lip open.
So, I had, like,
a bloody mouth and --
kid in a sweatshirt, Batman,
and I jumped off a stoop
after I got candy.
And I go, "I'm Batman"
or whatever,
and I jumped off,
and it was so cheap
that the costume just ripped.
[ Light laughter ]
I had, like, jeans
on underneath,
but I ended up just being a kid
in jeans and a t-shirt.
-With a mouth --
-With a bloody lip.
-Sweatshirt, jeans --
-Yeah, and a bloody lip. Yeah.
That was probably the worst one.
But I don't know,
I've had bad ones.
This first one here is
from @JodieColombo.
-Ooh!
-She says,
"My grandmother wrapped
my cousin up in tinfoil
for Halloween and said he was
a Hershey's Kiss,
everyone thought
he was leftovers."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
[ Applause ]
Leftovers are good costumes.
-I'm going as old lasagna.
[ Light laughter ]
This one is from @MemeFinder69.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Wow. [ Laughs ]
What?
I hope that was for
"MemeFinder."
-Yeah, he was probably born
in 1969.
-Yeah, sure.
-He says, "I went as
a hand last Halloween.
I spent the whole night
getting hit in the face."
Like...
High five, high five.
Ow.
[ Smack ]
High five. Ow.
[ Laughter ]
High five, nerd.
[ Smack ]
Ow.
-MemeFinder.
-This one's from @RachelLees.
She says, "In 2017 we all went
out as a family group
of superheroes -- Superman,
Supergirl, and Wonder Woman.
At the last second, my youngest
demanded she dress as poop."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, Superpoop.
-This one's from @KellytheWalsh.
She said, "I got 50 people at
my high school to wear all gray
and sunglasses so we could be
50 Shades of Grey.
I was told it wasn't
school appropriate,
and we had to enter the costume
contest as pavement."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's pretty good.
-Yeah.
-I like that one.
-You're not going to win, kid.
-Sexy pavement.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ms-emily-allen.
She says, "I dressed
as Ariana Grande
for a Halloween party.
On the street, a kid yelled,
"Look, Mom, it's old Ariana.'"
[ Laughter ]
-There's no need for that.
-Thank you, next.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @JoAnnNJ1.
Says, "I'm a teacher,
and our school Halloween parade
was that day.
I grabbed a cat costume from
the first store I passed.
Halfway through the parade
another teacher told me
it said "naughty little kitty"
on the back.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Uh, Miss Palmer.
-Excuse me.
-This last one here is
from @RickEGreen.
He says, last year I strapped
a bicycle tire to my neck
and just sit next
to the couples all night,
I was the third wheel.
-Oh.
-There you go.
There you have it,
those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check our more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.